when should you leave a tip American
sound off on cultural pressure oh wow
such terrible pressure people are having
right now if you enjoy eating gout
then you could be feeling uh growing
cultural pressures around one of the
service Industries most controversial
topics tipping tipping at Quick Service
and to go establishments is frustrating
creates a social pressure saying nursing
students and CNA Addison read day trader
Sean McDonald and Reed Express
frustration at the expectation to tip
for drive-through or to go services and
say they run into the issues frequently
Reed says she tips 15 on average for
quick Food Services and feels obligated
to tip when the worker is standing there
watching her McDonald's says he would
tip for good quality service but Express
concern about whether the gratuity goes
to the server the store owner or
corporate McDonald's suggested
businesses include fine print on their
tipping prompt specifying where the tip
goes so Adam go to you first thoughts on
tips I'm minutes nothing's more Awkward
than just ordering some food it's you
know you go to Chicken Kitchen across
the street it's 11 12 bucks for your
meal then they hit you with how much do
you want to leave as a tip two three
four five it's like
okay now I'm face to face with the lady
she's like looking at you like so what's
she gonna do yeah but you're not gonna
give me three extra dollars for giving
you your foot it's like now it's awkward
I'm gonna I'm gonna assume I'm gonna
guess that she's Latina yeah with that
voice I just did right there but and I I
hate that by the way I hate awkward
moments they should have like you don't
voting you go on that little thing give
me like a tip room why go in there don't
just stand there and make it weird yeah
yeah how much you're gonna tell me here
how much I'm gonna I just handed you
your food yeah can you turn around
please like this is awkward yeah I mean
like it's either after using this if
they're using the system by square or
toast they just turn the iPad around you
yeah and then they Point uh yeah just
right there yeah and they're staring at
you so um I'm not going to name the name
of it but we take the girls and we love
to go out to
um it's a very creative dessert place
that uh makes you know frozen yogurt and
they use nitrogen it's real fun
and I asked one time I said hey if I tip
here where does this go and the girl
there says oh I don't know oh great and
so obviously it doesn't go to me because
otherwise she would cheerfully say oh it
goes to us we split it whoever's on
shift we split it
um like if you ever had you ask a valet
do I tip you I'll just put it on the
thing we split it yeah yeah you know uh
and so I'm I'm not on the tip thing on
the the retail cash register if I'm just
buying something you're handing it to me
we didn't have tips for many many years
and I'm not convinced that the the core
workers are getting it if I know the
workers getting it and they've done
something nice I will take care of that
person I agree I agree 100 I'm not I'm
I'm with them and mind you I I tip
really really well and I don't even have
money like that because I know I'm being
exactly I tip to where sometimes they
walk away and they go are you and I'm
being dead serious like I went to go eat
with Kelly Kelly I tipped them I even
asked I go how much could I feel bad if
I go under but the the fact that the
girl just stays there I I'm at the point
in my life I'm 44 I go excuse me can you
just at least look over there it's just
awkward because I'm putting it and then
you're sitting there looking at it it
makes me feel it makes me feel you give
the old look over there you reach in and
you grab the tip out exactly I go fire
and I just
Bernie Mac told a joke about her looking
at him do you know this is a dirty joke
it's a [__] awesome joke there you go
here it comes the time I can't say oh
yeah
Bernie Mac is my guy but uh God bless
his soul yeah two-year-old she the
shepherd for the devil you know whatever
she says the other two [__]
dude
you tell the story about your uncle that
doesn't even speak English and him
downstairs what do you mean him that is
yeah you should walk two four
six-year-old Bernie was good what's his
what's his joke
actually hurting everybody
what's the joke with the tip he'll tell
us after Bernie Mac 30. so anyways so uh
uh tipping
um yeah if the money doesn't go to them
I don't uh over tip if the money is like
a pool like if they do a pool tip I
don't like that like you know sometimes
valet they'll do a pull tip I'm like
yeah can I give it to you no it's gonna
go to pool okay so here's 20 bucks I was
gonna give you 100 bucks but here's 20
bucks Hey where's this going to go this
is going to go to me fantastic so here's
a tip that goes to you now
if service is bad will you tip zero say
you go to a restaurant it is absolutely
horrible Tom insult late annoying
nothing they do is Right absolutely
horrible will you tip zero yes I will if
it is a hundred percent on the server
but if the kitchen was slow there's
other things there and they've got like
seven tables and they're running around
they didn't have enough people there
very good then I cut some slack but if I
know it's just that person their
attitude forgot the order putting the
wrong order you know just or you know
the the the one I hate is the appetizers
comes out in 13 seconds later somebody
else comes out of the kitchen with the
dinner and I'm like I didn't ask you to
appetizer doesn't give us a little time
yeah and that's all on the screen are
you ready for this back so me me and
Kelly yesterday went to go eat ramen now
it's really good spot right normally
when you walk in there's one one of the
waitresses hi she's welcoming times it's
an experience she's awesome right this
girl I could already tell from the
beginning we sat there me Kelly are
chilling and then Pat nothing is I have
to I had to walk to a table get the menu
I brought the menu we'll look into it I
order an appetizer we order the meal uh
I I got Arnold Palmer we like it's we
like it the same way I go little iced
tea that she shows up it's all lemonade
she goes I trust me I put iced tea she
didn't I asked for I see it on the side
should our ramen comes no appetizer I
don't say anything and then all this it
was just the worst she was young or
whatever I still I even asked I will
tell you Kelly how much and we even put
even more than unless they do something
personal to me like hey but and I told
her no we don't want it I still feel bad
unless they're an [__] or all I'm
saying to you is DM Vinnie to come to
your arrest because whether you give
shitty service or not he's gonna tip I
feel bad for the person because you're
such a socialist at rest I'll add one
more thing Tom when you when you give
the zero tip do you give any insight or
any encouragement to the server meaning
like I've been a server before and I I
think server is actually a great job if
you want to do anything in sales you're
out there you're working you have a
system you gotta you know meet with
people you know you're upselling it's
such a great job to kind of to
understand people and social dynamics
but if there's someone who's a shitty
server the last thing I'll do is just
tip them nothing and be like and because
that's gonna these [__] people they
don't it's like I'll say Hey listen I'm
a 20 guy across the board decent service
great service 20 unless unless there's
something extra I would say Hey listen
I'm a 20 tip guy sorry to let you know
you did not deserve meet the standard
but I'm gonna tip you so and I don't
want you to feel like things are you
know that you didn't do your job but the
next time I come here the next customer
just understand that they're probably
not going to tip you like this because
your service was pretty poor here's some
money it's eight bucks whatever it is
but you know keep improving I actually
like that a lot more I just hate those
awkward moments you guys are very Noble
I may write something I may write like
something simple that says like I don't
know what's going on what's up and I'll
say that I don't know what's up but the
service was non-existent oh you're gonna
write the note I love it you have a pen
on you or do you ask them for a pen or
no I'll use no if they've given me
enough because nothing's more Awkward
hey can I buy it
no no no I mean you ain't [__] no they
bring your credit card back with the
with the slip yeah by the way I'm not
mean I don't just say it's unfortunate
your mom was pro-life you know what
you know
you know it's like
I'm taking a stand
well she's just she's going to see her
head come up like who the hell was that
by the way if you want to hear real
stories with restaurants Mario moral T
grin will tell you plenty of stories of
what happens with restaurants I've
walked in Hostess was bad I'll walk at
him he's beautiful uh waitress is bad
you know or wait waiter is bad you know
we'll have the conversation but the best
thing to do is to follow it here's what
you don't here's what we don't do enough
of if the waiter or the waitress is
great
I always do this I love doing this I'll
say
um can I talk to your manager please and
they'll always say oh God is everything
fine and I'll say it in a very serious
tone it's fine but I need to speak with
your manager immediately and then they
walk away and they're like oh like what
happened we and they'll say is there
anything I can do I'm telling you I need
to speak with the manager is it the food
is there anything I can do so then the
manager will show up and you see them
watching from a distance on what we're
saying to the manager to say what's your
name Johnny Johnny how long you been the
manager here three years I got to tell
you Johnny I don't know what you do here
I have no idea what you do with your
guys but our waitress was absolutely
amazing
she was phenomenal kind respectful on
time the iced tea lemonade Arnold Palmer
90 10 Flawless she brought the balsamic
glaze she brought the honey uh uh asking
if we'd like more three refills she
wasn't just bringing one refill and
walking away not coming back up she's a
perfect so whatever service you guys got
fantastic please make sure she knows
about it I want to make sure you knew
about it she's amazing you guys are
lucky to have her that's amazing and
then they come back the waitress and by
the way ever like eight out of ten times
when you say this they bring you free
dessert 100 and it's like you know that
happens we got this don't worry about
this we got that but you know I think if
you're gonna give the negative feedback
you also have to give the positive
feedback if they crush it I agree they
crush it give them the one I agree
phenomenal so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here